In my culture death is
not the end it's more of a stepping off point
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full black panther wakanda forever breakdown
and easter eggs for the entire movie there's
a whole bunch of stuff that they set up during
this we have to talk about if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos and careful for spoilers for the
movie if you haven't seen it yet but we'll
just start at the beginning work our way through
shop by shot talking about Easter eggs WTF moments
and all the teasers for the upcoming movies the
whole opening scene of the movie is meant to be
t'challa's actual death with shuri trying to
find a way to recreate the heart-shaped herb
using science claiming that taking the herb again
will be able to heal whatever's killing him I know
this is going to be a huge question like what
did he actually die from in the MCU they never
actually reference what it is they only say that
he lived with a disease for a long time secretly
not telling any of his family members except for
Nakia he told Nakia after she became pregnant with
their son also named t'challa his Haitian name he
goes by is Toussaint in order to hide his identity
the other big easter egg for the comics here is
that in the comics Black Panther's son is with
storm his name is sorry and he gets both storms
powers and becomes the next Black Panther and has
all of his powers his mutant powers are basically
the same as Storm's Powers he has electrokinesis
I'm assuming the version of the MCU is just
going to be a normal human until he takes the
heart-shaped herb it is always possible that they
do introduce a version of storm though in Black
Panther 3 because she is Queen of her tribe in
Africa so there were any movie to introduce her
in the Black Panther movies would be the place to
do it I think the mystery disease is just meant to
be a parallel for Chadwick boseman's death in real
life secretly having cancer through the filming
of all of his Marvel movies back to the events of
Captain America Civil War that was around the time
when he actually was diagnosed with cancer and
he just kept it to himself like he didn't tell
the Marvel people he didn't tell any of his fans
maybe his wife knew about it but that's about it
when he was filming the first Black Panther movie
The Avengers Infinity War Avengers endgame movies
he was suffering through cancer and it was really
bad at that point later in the movie she does wind
up being able to use namor's underwater strain
of the heart-shaped herb another type of plant
that grew and underwater vibranium tainted soil
that would have saved him but it also enables her
to become the next Black Panther and will also
allow t'challa's son to become the next Black
Panther after her when he comes of age later and
possibly even meet his father in The ancestral
plane I know there's all kinds of theories about
what they could do with t'challa's character or
how they'd use him in future stories because
Chadwick Boseman is dead they're not going to
bring him back in a really big way but they
could always say that he does become the new
Panther God if they kill off the Bast Panther
goddess they're a couple different times in the
comics when Black Panther actually does become
a God speaking of gods another big thing we've
been talking about this year in Marvel movies
and Marvel Disney plus series are the way the
gods exist in the MCU Thor love and thunder Moon
Knight Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness in
one of the most surprising things to me in this
opening scene was that we were learning for the
first time that shuri never really believed in
Bast the panther goddess she never thought that
she was real because as a last resort she finally
praised to her saying that I will finally believe
in you if you help save my brother but the thing
is is that us as the audience saw a bast in Thor
Love and Thunder we know that Bast is real we've
seen Thor Thor's an actual God in the MCU so we
know that Gods actually exist so it was kind of
weird to me that shuri did not believe that gods
exist she also didn't believe her mother when she
was talking about the ancestral plane I've seen
visions of your brother she was talking about
seeing t'challa in the ancestral plain early in
the movie shuri brushed that off claiming that
it was just a trick of her mother's mind like
you weren't really seeing our brother I think
the point at which she starts to believe though
is when she actually takes the new version of the
heart-shaped herb and sees killmonger she travels
to the ancestral plane like oh this is all real
one of the other big introductions during this
intro scene is her new AI it's actually voiced by
Trevor Noah you probably recognize the voice later
her mother even has an Ultron reference when she
starts joking about the AI going rogue sure he's
like no it's totally safe it does whatever I
tell it to do but we know that's not totally
true because we know about Ultron Avengers Age of
Ultron they never reference this plot Point again
during the movie the AI itself going rogue so they
might just be setting up a future plot line that
they'll pay off in some other movie maybe black
panther 3 maybe something else the whole idea
that shuri has too much faith in her technology
it's the same thing to happen to Iron Man during
Avengers Age of Ultron too curious and too smart
for your own Goods sometimes like curiosity kill
the cat in that metaphor makes so much more sense
now in the context of black panther because she is
kind of like a cat a really big really stabby cat
but the whole movie is full of moments like this
with like little beats that feel like they're
setting up something really huge in the future
that they never fully pay off by the end of the
movie like we're gonna take care of this in a
future movie during t'challa's funeral at the
beginning the reason why they're wearing white
and white seems kind of like a party for some of
them is because in a lot of cultures around the
world they wear white to funerals instead of black
particularly that part of Africa and the reason
they're celebrating is because they're celebrating
t'challa's life while mourning him at the same
time like through the process of mourning they
are celebrating his life thematically the entire
movie is written to be awake for t'challa in and
surely learning to grieve him and then per their
Customs move on with the future and for most of
the movie she can't do that like she can't move on
the reason why they take t'challa's body away in
the ship is because inside wakanda they bury the
previous Kings inside the necropolis they call
it the City of the Dead we saw it in the first
movie that's where they kept the heart-shaped
herb before killmonger burned it inside the
necropolis they have a very special place for the
actual previous black panthers the previous Kings
they call it literally the Hall of Kings once a
young t'challa comes of age we'll probably see
him in that place looking at his father's tomb in
the comics black panther also gains the power to
speak to the previous black panthers it's kind of
like avatar the Airbender where they can summon up
the past lives and learn from their knowledge they
might wait till his son comes of age and becomes
the next Black Panther before they pay off that
plot point though they have the special tribute
version of Marvel Studios intro logo with just
Chadwick Boseman they did the same thing for Stan
Lee after he passed away like the Stanley version
of the intro scene the other difference we with
the Black Panther version is that it's totally
silent they don't play the Marvel Fanfare like
they did with Stan Lee they have a one-year time
Jump so that means that t'challa died about two
years after Avengers end game in the majority of
the movie is meant to take place about three years
after Avengers endgame around the same time as
Ant-Man and the wasp Quantumania because there's
an Easter egg for Scott Lang's book that we see
during Ant-Man quantumania it's called look out
for the little guy and it's on one of the chirons
they did the same thing during Spider-Man no way
home with an Easter egg for Thor love and thunder
that was a reference to new Asgard during one of
Jay Jonah Jameson's Daily Bugle news broadcasts
at the United Nations we learned the rest of
the world as pissed off at wakanda and they
want their vibranium their resources because
they're still kind of in rebuilding mode after
Avengers end game this becomes a big plot point
for Val's character and they'll probably pay it
off during Captain America 4 New World Order in
the Thunderbolts movie because Val wants vibranium
and she very literally told Everett Ross I dream
of the time when America controls all vibranium
on the planet Richard Schiff is playing the new
secretary of state he took over for Thunderbolt
Ross he used to be the Secretary of State back
during the events of Captain America's Civil
War which is why I think they wanted to recast
Thunderbolt Ross with Harrison Ford and use him
in a big way during Captain America 4 because
he'll be a big part of that we meet Anika for
the first time she's a member of the midnight
Angels she's also from the comics they debut in
the movie with shuri's new suits that she and
akoye wear and if it wasn't clear Anika is also
meant to be ao's lover Ayo also winds up becoming
the new general the new leader of the door milaje
taking over for Okoye when she gets fired during
the movie we find out that the United States
government essentially tricked Riri Williams
ironheart character into creating a vibranium
detector which the United States has been using
to try and find underwater vibranium there's
been a lot of theories about what's going on
behind this I think this is where we get to our
Doctor Doom plot in Easter eggs in the MCU in the
movie Riri Williams says she doesn't know anything
about the US government being involved with her
vibranium detector she just created it because one
of her MIT professors dared her to do it and she
just thought that she was doing it for a class
assignment they never referenced the professor
by name but it's the professor Who tricked her
and then sold it to the US government I think the
professor is probably going to wind up being the
leader some of you asked if Dr Doom would wind up
being the mystery Professor but I don't think that
he would secretly be a professor MIT but here's
the thing Lake Bell in the movie is supposed to
be playing a version of Lucia Von Barda who is
like Dr Doom's right-hand person from lobberia
in the movie she's only credited as Dr Graham
and they never referenced her by name but she's
much too big of an actor in such a seemingly small
one-off role to be just a nobody so I think the
idea is that Dr Doom is searching for vibranium
just like the Americans are and he's using her
as a plant inside the United States government
so it's sort of Doctor Doom pulling the strings
from behind so you have Val and Thunderbolt Ross
trying to get their hands on vibranium but really
it's Doctor Doom playing them for fools tooting
his horn from the Shadows so to speak they never
mention him by name in the movie but the whole
World versus wakanda plot over vibranium in
the movie is them adapting some of the Doomwar
storyline from the comics where he literally
invades wakanda to steal their vibranium also
shuri becoming the next Black Panther happened
right after the Doom War Arc so there are a lot
of Doctor Doom Easter eggs happening in the movie
but nobody actually mentions him by name it's
always possible that he could come back and be
a much bigger villain during black panther 3 or
they'll probably use him in some other way in the
MCU there's rumors about more Easter eggs for him
during the Ironheart series because Ironheart
season 1 is meant to be all about the balance
between Magic and technology and that is like
core Doctor Doom man of science man of magic but I
don't think the Doctor Doom character is supposed
to actually be in the ironheart series they're
just slowly establishing him in the MCU like
you'll see Easter eggs for him in the background
and at the end of the movie when shuri tells namor
that she'll help protect his underwater vibranium
from the rest of the world and Riri Williams isn't
going to create any more vibrating detectors it
essentially means the United States Doctor Doom
anyone else is out of luck for vibrate unless
they invade wakanda short term which I think
they'll pay off with Val in the Thunderbolts
trying to get vibranium in the Thunderbolts movie
maybe Captain America 4. I am sure once it gets
to that Bucky will have something to say about it
like there's no way Bucky would willingly want to
invade wakanda because he owes them so much but
I think that'll just be part of the drama like
the whole idea that they'll be forced to fight
them and Bucky will have to go Rogue that's one
of the reasons why Val told us agent that she
would need him because she couldn't call on real
Captain America the Falcon version for some of
these things obviously he wouldn't want to invade
wakanda but U.S agent wouldn't have a problem
with that we meet the MCU version of atlanteans
for the first time but remember some big changes
about their backstory now they're based more on
Mayan Aztec culture and their City isn't Atlantis
it's talocan they didn't change their backstory or
namor's backstory for rights reasons or anything
like that they just wanted it to feel like a real
culture inside the world like it could have
happened the same way that a lot of the other
Marvel stuff and mostly so that it didn't feel
like a copy of the Aquaman movie just like bast
the panther goddess came to bashenga and told
him where to find the heart-shaped herb about
10.000 years ago namor's God came to his mother's
people about 500 years ago and did the same thing
for them with the underwater heart-shaped herb we
actually do see the god of namor's people in Thor
love and thunder he's sitting right next to bast
the god of black panthers people or some of Black
Panther's people not all of them worshiped the
panther goddess for instance umbaku comes from
the ape tribe they worship the ape God he even
invokes his name during the movie praying to him
a lot of you've also asked if namor's underwater
vibranium meteorite is the same meteorite that
killed the dinosaurs or the same one that brought
tiama to planet Earth it's not the one that killed
the dinosaurs because that one fell in the Gulf
of Mexico it Atlantis is supposed to be here in
the Atlantic on Nick Fury's map much closer to
where wakanda is it is possible that this is
part of the seed that brought Tiamat to planet
Earth like that's where the vibranium came from
and just pieces of it broke off and one went to
wakanda and one went to the Atlantic Ocean because
celestials in in the comics do use vibranium to
make their bodies it changed their physiology to
what it is now but his mother was pregnant with
him when she took it and he was born a mutant
around the 1500s that's why I said he's meant to
be about 500 years old when the movie begins so he
has a bunch of extra powers like all of his Comic
Book powers but they're because he's a mutant not
because of the heart-shaped herb which is why the
atlanteans don't all have the same powers that he
does currently this makes him the oldest mutant
in the MCU that we've seen so far apocalypse and
Seline are older mutants in the comics but
because we haven't seen versions of them in
the MCU yet technically Namor is the oldest one
so far and essentially he's a Mesoamerican Aztec
Mayan version of comic book Namor he also says his
trademark catchphrase from the comics later in the
movie imperius rex Loosely it translates to Latin
meaning Empire King he uses it as Battle Cry kind
of like wakanda and say wakanda forever before
they start attacking he's got organic Wings on
his feet he can fly the way that he talks about
it though it's swimming through the sky that's
also the way they visualize is flying too it
looks like he's literally swimming through the
sky just like in the comics he's about as strong
as the Hulk when he's in contact with water that
is a comic book thing when he's not he's still
very strong just not nearly as strong all the
regular citizens of talocan are basically kind of
like low-level super soldiers because their DNA
has been changed by the heart-shaped herb like
every single member of their culture is like a
low-level super soldier their way stronger than
normal they heal faster which is why they're so
formidable against the wakandans which is why
namor says you cannot stand against my Army
when they meet namor for the first time at the
beach the shell that he gives them is also just
another comic book reference don't toot the horn
unless you mean business namor also tells them
that his mother told him stories about wakanda
when he was young almost 500 years ago just
charting the timeline of wakanda within the MCU
bashenga the first black panther was born about
10,000 years ago so wakanda would have existed for
a long time already by then inside the throne room
there's a cool Easter egg tribute to Chadwick
Boseman in real life on the inscriptions around
the pillars in the room decoded they all say
rest in Power King t'challa our hero it has been
in honor of wakanda forever they bring back the
Everett Ross character he's listening to Red Hot
Chili Peppers he helps them rescue Riri Williams
and they use a lot of his storyline with Val to
set up Thunderbolts in the Captain America 4
movie we learned that he used to be married to
Val and when Okoye rescues him from prison at
the end of the movie that's more of a setup for
secret Invasion because Martin Freeman Everett
Ross will be back in secret Invasion working
with Nick Fury obviously is a fugitive now because
he's still supposed to be in prison we meet Riri
Williams who goes to MIT like Tony Stark like
Spider-Man was trying to get into MIT in fact
because this happens a little bit after the events
of Spider-Man no way home MJ and Ned Leeds might
actually be going here at this point obviously
because Riri Williams ironheart is so connected
to Iron Man in the comics or origin story there
are a lot of Iron Man references in Easter eggs
during her scenes shuri references Stark Tech
a few times her mark one is meant to be kind
of like Iron Man's mark one you see her banging
with the hammer the exact same way that he did
she even has her own version of the cave scene
where they bust out of her garage like Iron Man
busted out of the cave her first flight is meant
to be similar to Iron Man's first flight in his
Mark II with the joke about the oxygen levels and
the suit kind of conking out until it got close to
falling to the ground and at the end of the movie
shuri winds up helping her build her Mark II suit
out of vibranium but makes her leave the suit in
wakanda when she goes back the Ironheart series
is meant to be a direct sequel to the events of
black panther wakanda forever she has her Mark 3
suit during that and now we know why because shuri
wouldn't let her take the vibranium suit with her
inside her dorm room the flag above her bed is the
flag of Chicago in the United States that's where
she's from it's probably where mostly ironheart
series is going to take place when Everett Ross
finds shuri's camoyo beads Val reveals she bugged
them because she knew about his connection with
wakanda and expected him to speak with them on
the DL and wanted to play on that to see if she
could get any more information and it just the way
to show you that Val is way smarter and way more
devious than she comes off because she's kind
of a jokey character when raimonda fires Okoye
as general the door milaje the real reason they
had her do that obviously is to set up the Okoye
Disney plus series they have to have a reason for
her to leave wakanda in the door milage also she's
going to continue being one of the midnight angels
with Anika you also noticed that raimonda says her
entire family is gone not dead because she always
knew this whole time about t'challa's son so even
if shuri had died during the movie her entire
family would not be dead she'd have her grandson
when shuri and riru Williams are taken to Tallow
can she makes a bunch of Pop Culture references
even Spider-Man would be proud of her Princess
Leia in Empire Strikes Back because she changed
her clothes in Empire Strikes Back Belle from
Beauty and the Beast the white chick from Indiana
Jones is a reference to Raiders of the Lost Ark
with Marion changing her clothes at the end of
the movie like when someone is asked to change
their clothes something bad always follows the
underwater entrance to talocan is also meant to be
similar to the security methods that will wakanda
has about getting through the shield they have
a special underwater current that they have to
unleash first which acts as sort of like a slip
stream that they travel through that takes them
to the actual city and what they're looking at
here is just the capital the Empire itself is much
bigger but the giant orb that emits all that light
sort of like your makeshift sun that comes out is
made entirely of vibranium when namor explains his
full backstory to shuri he explains his name Namor
in the MCU version is meant to be a translation
of his language meaning no love because he has
no love for the surface dwellers in the comics the
reason why his name is Namor is because it's just
Roman spelled backwards then when Namor winds up
flooding wakanda that's meant to be an adaptation
of when he did it in the comics during the Phoenix
Arc is basically the same situation like he just
flooded the entire city killing a whole bunch
of people after Namor kills raimonda sure uses
the remnants of namor's heart-shaped herb to
recreate it using her lab and uses it to become
the next Black Panther just like she became the
next Black Panther after The do-more Arc in the
comics another big Doctor Doom connection when
she enters the ancestral plane the reason why
she winds up in the throne room is because she
thought that she would see her mother and that's
the place where her mother died the reason why
it winds up being killmonger is because of her
desire for revenge against namor like killmonger
says inside your heart subconsciously you really
wanted me that's why you called to me it also
winds up proving the reality of the ancestral
plane and all this mystical stuff that she
didn't totally believe in before this when
she creates her version of the Black Panther
suit because it's so inspired by killmonger
that's why it has all the gold all over it like
it's a combination of t'challa's black panther
suit in killmonger's flashier Golden Jaguar suit
is also why her suit seems so stabby looking The
Mask has the same tribal markings on it that she
has on her face and it functions a lot like Iron
Man's Avengers Infinity war and Avengers end game
nanite armors like the suit just creates anything
she needs at any given moment using vibrating
nanites the only difference from Iron Man's
armors is that he didn't have vibranium that's why
she can automatically form the same Sonic cannons
around her hands like the fixed ones she wore in
the first Black Panther movie and when the armor
isn't deployed like the full suit it exists inside
that golden necklace that she wears that you see
at the end of the movie t'challa's and killmongers
also came out of their necklaces too when she
returns to embaku the rest of the elders in the
New Black Panther suit it's important to note that
imbaku is on the same page with shuri and wants
to help her despite their initial disagreement
over killing namor and starting a never-ending
War even though he's going to be king now at the
end of the movie when he says shuri will not
be joining us today it's because he and sure
he already worked out the details of how wakanda
would be managed going forward so there's already
like a very clear understanding between the two
of them how this is gonna work he would take
over the rulership of wakanda day-to-day stuff
and she would just continue being black panther
working in her lab at least until t'challa's son
comes of age and combines those two roles again
like the king of wakanda and the Black Panther
at the same time we get the name or imperius
Rex mentioned and then sure he sees a vision of
her mother in The ancestral plane finally who
urges her to show compassion like show him who you
really are they come to an agreement call truce
and shuri agrees that wakanda going forward will
help them protect their underwater vibranium from
the rest of the world but the whole thing with
namor's ending scene when he's talking to namora
is that he's just biting his time waiting for the
rest of the surface world like Val for instance
Dr Doom to invade wakanda to get their vibranium
hoping that it will force sure his hand to form an
alliance with them and then they can burn down the
rest of the world umbagu formally becomes king in
the same ceremony that we saw during the first
Black Panther movie Riri Williams goes home to
Chicago and to her ironheart series Okoye rescues
Everett raw so that he can go help Nick Fury
during the secret Invasion series I believe those
episodes will drop around March next year it'll be
like the first Marvel Disney plus series of 2023
we'll get a new trailer for that really soon so
of course I'll do more bonus videos when we do and
we get our big post-credits scene where we learn
about t'challa's son I've already done a really
big video about this so I'll link it at the end of
this down in the description below but the basic
idea is that Marvel is now just going to make him
the New Black Panther in the new king of wakanda
once he becomes old enough he'll also probably be
on Young Avengers teams we'll see him in a bunch
of other movies while he's slowly growing up the
big question now is whether or not Marvel is gonna
pull some tiny whimey crazy Quantumania type of
trick with Kang to age him up super fast like will
he come of age in Black Panther 3 relatively soon
or will it be black panther 4 or some other movie
after that post all your theories about that like
how long is Marvel going to wait before young
t'challa is old enough to become the next Black
Panther you also probably recognize during the
end credits they also play Rihanna's song that
she wrote just for the movie and they have a
special tribute to Chadwick Boseman t'challa
when shuri is doing her grieving ceremony like
finally burning her garments from his funeral
there's like a billion things that happened during
this movie that we can talk about I have a bunch
of bonus videos planned and obviously there's
a bunch of other big stuff coming up too like
Ant-Man 3 Quantumania is the next big movie so
there'll be more trailers for that later this
year too so there'll be a bunch of Kang videos
coming everyone click here for that black panther
wakanda forever post credit scene video and click
here for my Ant-Man 3 Quantumania trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!